hé il y a une confiance entre moi et mes
chiens d'abord il
y a la confiance entre moi mais quand
ils veulent courir ils vont
me fuir je vais perdre la paire que l'autre
chose donc ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on utilise des crochets quand
nous nous arrêtons avec nous espérons faire du traîneau ce que nous
appelons venir au grenier et les chiens ne vont
nulle part ailleurs mais si le crochet se détache,
ils s'enfuiront quand vous perdrez
tout vous ne vous sentez pas sûr même avec l'
attelage de chiens si vous perdez vous êtes amarré  vous
ne vous sentez pas sûr parce qu'il y a des
ours polaires partout et pour cette
raison, cela affecte mon esprit et quand
ils sont partis, les chiens se sont enfuis, c'était mal en
fait, en plus, je n'aurai pas de camion,
rien pour voyager, je devrai marcher
vous savez si mais si je mais si j'apprends à mes
chiens comment revenir comment
revenir et ces choses, ils apprendront
cela pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
problème, il ne devrait pas y avoir de
problème entre moi et mon  les chiens c'est quand
ils sont heureux mais c'est quand ils veulent
y aller c'est  c'est quand ils veulent
courir j'essaie de rester tout d'abord vous
leur apprenez la langue cela ne dit pas qu'un
chien apprendra n'importe quelle langue pour
apprendre à vos propres chiens la façon dont vous voulez
qu'ils courent comme vous le voulez
s'asseoir et des choses comme ça ça devait venir
du maître entre moi moi-même en tant que
maître et un autre maître on n'apprend peut être pas à
nos chiens de la même façon tout le monde est
différent un peu différent mais pour tourner
oui on le fait tous pareil tournez à gauche tournez à
droite  c'est la même chose d'arrêter
c'est la même chose mais d'autres choses comme
travailler plus dur ou courir plus vite ou s'installer
ou il est temps d'y aller
parfois utiliser une vraie voix ou la vraie vie
mais d'autres fois c'est entre moi et mes
chiens comment je pense que vous devez être
plus gentil avec vous comment être poli avec eux
à orland pour que vous et vos
chiens travailliez ensemble vous avez  travailler
ensemble et si j'écris  ng une voiture ou je
nous écris pour faire une motoneige ou un
quad tout seul je ne dis
rien mais mais quand je voyage avec des
chiens je dois utiliser ma voix pour
m'arrêter ou tourner ou plus vite ou  plus lent tu
sais ces choses j'utilise ma voix et
j'édite et c'est un morceau pour moi tu sais que
c'est un c'est un tu sais quand je
voyage je ne le suis pas et je ne
dis rien je suis assis  c'est
la pièce que je monte ici c'est la
liberté est celle que j'aime vivre
ici sur terre dans le Nord une liberté
entre moi et mes chiens je suis je suis un homme en
chêne mes chiens sont des chiens donc il y a une
culture entre nous  entre mon chien,
ils vont ils vont se battre avec du bacon ou ils
peuvent aboyer ou ils peuvent se mordre
c'est leur langage parmi ces
gars mais quand je leur apprends à ne pas suivre cet
ordre ou comment comment faire pour
que cela signifie l'arrêter  peut être que j'utilise à
deux voix ma propre voix j'utilise aussi la
voix du fouet de chien c'est un son que l'esprit du chien
fait me dire d'arrêter tu sais ces
choses un  je suis comme mais si c'est une
langue entre moi et mes chiens euh
dépend de qui vous êtes et comment vous le faites
et comment vous enseignez à vos chiens ils
écouteront ce que vous leur enseignez je pense
que c'est une grande chose parce que
quand le poids  parce que lorsque vous
apprenez à vos chiens comment faire
avec vous, ils travailleront avec vous,
donc en faisant cela, vous
travaillez réellement en équipe, c'est une équipe
que vous travaillez en tant que maître vos chiens,
j'ai dit en meute vous  sont un chien d'équipe, ils
feront une voix lorsque l'ours entrera
ou que quelqu'un d'autre entrera dans votre camp
ou qu'un autre chien entrera dans votre camp,
ils vous avertiront que vous entendez ce
qu'ils disent et que vous comprenez
parce que cela prend beaucoup de temps  il est temps de
vraiment comprendre le langage des chiens
il faut une eau c'est ma maison l'
environnement est ma maison et le parc les poupées
font partie de cet ensemble et nous travaillons
ensemble et c'est comme ça que nous savons mais dans un
blizzard ou un brouillard le plus épais je ne '  Je ne sais pas
comment rentrer à la maison parce qu'il n'y a pas de
route  annonces ici là-bas parfois vous
ne trouvez pas de sentiers car toute
la région est recouverte de
neige fraîche donc ces chiens ils savent
comment rentrer à la maison alors que je ne le ferais pas je serais
faible je serais perdu là-bas si je
n'avaient pas de chiens mais ces chiens ils
savent comment rentrer à la maison dans le blizzard ou
le brouillard le plus épais ou une très forte
chute de neige savent-ils comment rentrer à la maison
ils me ramèneront à la maison je ne leur dirais
rien mais ils se dirigeront vers
à la maison hé c'est ce que nous faisons
ce que je fais c'est que je nous ai juste accroché
22 à une ligne ou une trace ce que nous appelons une
trace donc c'est accroché et ici je
ne peux pas gérer je peux pirater je peux gérer le
chien  avec moi mais tu as promené le chien avec
moi et ainsi de suite ceci est cela fait
partie de cela ici fait partie de ce que j'ai l'
intention de l'avoir là
parce que je dois l'utiliser et c'est et cela
prend moins de temps pour obtenir  l'enlever et le
mettre et ainsi de suite au lieu d'avoir à vous
au lieu d'avoir à l'attacher cela prend
moins de temps mais e  tout ce que vous savez d'autre
ici à douter que tout le reste fait partie
du travail cela fonctionne c'est un
harnais qu'ils travaillent et ils l'utilisent
pour travailler avec moi c'est c'est en
partie c'est Martin c'est mon mon pense pas
là monsieur mais vous  sais comme ça je commence
par le dernier le plus court puis
je travaille mon chemin vers le plus long et de cette façon
quand j'accroche mon chien Miley ils savent qu'il a
fini et qu'il est temps d'y aller
certains chiens se battront plus je le docteur
ne fera pas ce chien plus  là, le loup se
battra avec se battra avec tous les autres
chiens peu importe combien de chiens
là-bas vous n'aurez jamais vraiment donc
il ne gagne jamais mais il n'abandonne jamais vraiment
en ce moment entre moi c'est le fils
de lui il a 12 ans  vieux dans un chien dans un
chien ans 12 fois 7 soit 48 84 ans
plus de 84 ans dans nos années
donc il ne travaille plus avec un attelage
il est là parce qu'il était bébé
avant que j'aie mon attelage de chiens et  frapper c'est
le chien de la ruelle sunkist parce qu'il il il est
le chien de tête être  parce qu'il ira
tout droit quand je lui dirai et
tout le monde suivra, il dit qu'il est le
seul chien de tête que j'ai maintenant, je peux obtenir d'
autres chiens de tête qui peuvent être
plus rapides, mais c'est généralement si les chiens
allument des ascenseurs en trois ans  c'est là
qu'ils courent mais après trois ans ils
commenceront à marcher peu importe
qu'ils courent ou non mais ils marcheront plus
que plus que courir c'est généralement les
chiens derrière eux qui le feront courir
chaque chien a son propre nom  parce que je
dois leur parler individuellement
parfois parfois je parle parler à
toute l'équipe comme tourner ou courir plus vite ou
s'arrêter ou partir vous savez ce sont la voix
que je fais à toute l'équipe
hé
il voulait être comme être  un patron c'est
pourquoi il se fait battre tout le temps
mais mais ils sont aussi le moment où je
dois leur parler individuellement,
qu'il y ait ou non d'autres autres
chiens là-dedans ou non ce gars se
battra c'est un c'est un  combattant d'autres chiens
ont dû être abattus  parce qu'ils étaient trop
durs et ce mec est comme ça pour tous les
costumes des autres je suis sale tu es
sale tu sais d'accord ouais ah le mauvais chien
j'ai appelé le mauvais chien qu'il est un mauvais chien
tout le monde c'était ce qu'il d'autre va bien
jeune  musa sait comme celui-ci est un
gagnant il ses oreilles flop quand il
marche c'est pourquoi je l'appelle clin d'œil tous les
autres chiens ont leur propre canoë de nom vous
pouvez faire vous voulez dire monsieur miley chien son nom
est Kenya et cela signifie cuivre en
anglais ceci  l'un est l'un des poissons
couleur de poisson et et vous savez que tous les autres chiens
ont leur propre nom et ouais je les nomme
la façon dont ils agissent parfois quelque chose
parfois ils ont l'air vous savez
comment je les nomme, c'est à quoi ils ressemblent ou
comment ils agissent
ces derniers  deux travaillent pour le
travaillent pour la ceinture qu'ils veulent être
ils veulent les battre le chien mature
immature parmi tous les autres parce
que parce que le chien plus âgé là-bas il il
est le il est le principal il il regarde il
s'occupe du social  structure des
chiens même s'il le fait  ne cours plus
pas comme s'il tombait il devient
trop vieux il perd son il est lâche il
pensait que son chien Hanks canines je pense que
je me souviendrais si nous nous inquiétons pour
qu'il ne se batte plus autant qu'il
avait l'habitude de  mais maintenant il y a les deux
chiens qui travaillent pour ce poste,
mon chien de tête est mon ordinateur portable, ils
travaillent pour ce genre de poste, donc
là, ils se battront dépend de qui gagne en
fonction de qui gagne tout le temps est le
bar est le patron qui va  m'occuper de la
structure de l'équipe je m'occuperai
de leur dur labeur à quelle vitesse ils
courent où allons-nous je m'occuperai de ça
mais parmi l'équipe comme celle-ci la
structure et la structure sociale de
l'équipe seront prises en charge par
c'est ce qu'ils sont si c'est une
c'est une équipe
vous